why does the suit make up our asses
makes us faster in the water you just
took my boobs
yeah not here here check is tan for
needle mark on smile posted that
Baywatch almost yet
welcome to Baywatch our team is the
elite of the elite for the heart soul of
this very Beach come on feet make my
patches a little bigger and don't cover
up my front bump you got it huge dick
big dick we're staring into the abyss
here it's up to us restore the Baywatch
brand hey One Direction you here for the
qualifiers I'm Matt Brodie I don't have
to try out I've got two gold medals
training begins at 600
[Applause]
what is it that you think we do here
prevent people from getting sunburned
occasionally stop them from drowning I
can't see your finger this is the guy
you think it's a good PR opportunity for
us look I get it
being sasquatch I'm fast [ __ ] in touch
you're in shock
drugs murder dead body on our Beach and
it all started once she took over some
people are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
that's best the truth is one of you will
probably die what no
the only one that thinks this is clearly
a job for the police Thank You blue-eyed
demon you got one job make sure swim
happy white people don't drown why did
she look like she's running in slow-mo
she's the reason I believe in God
we gotta go undercover
yeah undercover yeah little to
undercover
Jason Bourne and got [ __ ] on me why are
we in the morgue you got to get some
hard evidence what's coming what do we
do now now we hide where do you pick
something it's just a little dead man's
fat necrotic liquid fat then will you
stop being a baby
you
you